haha first a naked their body purse the
negative body hahaha like a big pinata
Oh
ah hi everybody welcome back to let's
play one life no longer exists okay um
oh yeah oh we're living off we need to
go up here um I'm trying to get over
there but that was wrong so I'm just
gonna pull this mysterious a different
colored book here and everything's gonna
be perfectly normal after that okay okay
all right
everybody look at that that's
distracting right okay going here with a
purple glow I knew there was some hair
so anyway well what's behind here ow my
face hurts from jumping off that one
bookshelf got him such a wimp oh well
this isn't good
hello mr. rat have you seen any monsters
over here woman why are you running
towards that mr. rat don't you would
have warned me about anything
No okay well let's see what we got
hello any diabolical monsters anything
crowbar oh I can open the door in the
library's main hall with this yeah I
said that I just said that thank you
very much mr. rat no more monsters good
there better not be or else do I'll be
held to pay not really
they'll be ragnarok to pay or whatever
it is
what's the Norse version of the end of
the hell is there a Norse version of
hell I have no idea
hahaha play with me no no no no no I
wonder why they just took away my
crowbar just so that they can give it
back to me that seems rather arbitrary
said rather strange okay Oh what what
when did it turn into a log cabin again
it's doesn't make any sense no hello
tiny painting dawn dawn dawn dawn is
there anything under there no it's only
been like one amnesia custom story
that's ever had anything behind there or
underneath the piano and I've looked
ever since hello what does it say
valkyries took me to Valhalla good for
you let me take a sward no I didn't
wanted yeah they took you to Valhalla ok
got it ok nothing there let me explore
what's over here this door won't open
well why is it even there then to the
hallway everyone no the party's at the
hallway I wonder what these pictures are
leading me to in the changeovers loading
screens as they're cold Oh as good nope
uh-huh I ignored that room before I can
ignore that one now alright I'll look in
it it didn't look as bad it was just a
rocking chair and just a few dead body
bridge hello rock rock you did yes
Ragnarok I really has no pertaining
reference here I just read a note before
you guys came in said something about
the end of the world
Ragnarok or something it's doraville not
open ever and why even make the door why
is the door even there if it's not gonna
help I don't care give me a candle
I haven't gotten new candles in a while
seriously they are being very skimpy on
the candles either that or I've missed
them because I can't sue cuz nothing has
a glow in here so
okay that's good all right okay got a
good feeling about this okay door Hey
look an axe thank good oh I can't pick
it up oh no so I won't open okay good
for that door
it is dark down here some kind of
unnatural darkness hello
doors will you stop banging open
what's with this saw very peculiar but
nothing that can help me ah whoa oh man
that was a good one that caught me
totally by surprise I loved it oh if you
missed it go back and look again because
I didn't see it till was halfway through
me I don't wake you up in the morning
goody goody gumdrops don't do that again
no do it again Oh get many good scares
how it's perfect not loud noises so
subtle whew I'm just harping on it
honking that scare was good anything
else oh no not my candle I need more
candles oh man I don't know why
sometimes when I get a really good scare
puts me in a good mood like I don't know
it's just sort of a masochistic effect
of playing these games so much but I
really like liked it anyway let's keep
going um I feel like I'm being led in a
circle here I feel like I've been here
before
um yes I've seen this before hello dog's
head and dead rabbit what the hell I've
been here before this is this one big
circle it leads to nothing bunch of dead
animals I guess but that doesn't really
help me right now hello crumpled bones
got any secrets to tell me
barrels of wine any secrets no on top of
you they're running out of no actually
this candle lasts quite a while but I
still need more
I always need more okay I'm kind of at a
loss here where am I going from now
because I've been around this place a
few times I don't think I've missed
anything have I have I have I missed
anything maybe down here hello is
anybody home
ah yes he thank you hello mr. rat aha
key a boiler room entrance key in a
hammer don't need the hammer hello
anybody in here and shadows want to pop
out of me again
okay curative liquid not that I've been
hurt that much I'm gonna jump down about
5 feet and smash my legs open but that's
okay I hear you
where are you and where's the boiler
room I have no idea which one of these
is the boiler room so how much most
should know it's not like they have a
sign is there a sign maybe there's a
sign huh boom okay not that one not that
one which one is it then why was this in
the process of being bricked up why why
is this the boiler room it looks like
the boiler room maybe there'll be some
pipes going to it over here maybe this
was the boiler room
hello mister boiler room sir wait a
minute I see another thing over there
can a crowbar you open no I said crowbar
nope okay I hear a monster but he's not
coming out Daria
hi ah how's it going bro
Pam mcdougal of Gillick honey I need to
get around you so you want to move your
fat ass you didn't see anything you
didn't hear anything
kill me running oh it's a boiler room
well this is the boiler room where the
Ning got always it over here is this
abuela love it it is I bet it is
ah come on where's the dingdong damn
boiler room hey you didn't hear a damn
thing if you did you thought wrong take
a barrel thank you go away for the hell
well no I got the key from here this
does not help me are you on the other
side
hey can I get a stop it I need to go
through there Ivan had to resort to this
method in a long time what don't you
come employ mr. fat man throws cake did
that hurt I hope of dead okay so the
door is obviously not down here so I
need to get back upstairs is there
something here nope nothing here nope
okay I'm out of here
peace out go to hell died of fire how
about that just work with that so was
the boiler room entrance up here damn
room damn damn the boiler room ah noise
ah first I need to go to the south and I
need to find my way to the boiler room
where the boiler room were the boiler
room
I got a keygen worse the boiler
um where's your boiler wrong it's gotta
be down here
where's your boy or wrong I'm the
monster now mr. monster barn
where's the damn boiler room is it here
oh come on
son of a [ __ ] oh why couldn't you make
that door the unlockable one it would
have been more of a yes okay all right
we made it through here there's a pile
of bones but no time for that
we are going forward again to the boiler
room oh ha ha you can't fool me that's a
trick that's a trick see trick if I
stand on that I'd fall down wouldn't I
let's stand on that oh I thought that
was gonna fall down I thought it was
gonna fall down it really looked like it
was gonna okay never mind then my
mistake I was thinking otherwise
fine fine what's under the stairs
anything anything anything please
something anything teddy bear no
absolutely nothing under the stairs what
is the point there's always so much
potential am I the only gamer that
always checks under the stairs you
always check under the stairs okay so
what do we have here
not really I mean don't really need this
it's actually kind of relatively seeable
in here so let's pull this [ __ ]
uh-huh I done goof I goof bed anyway oh
it was so nice for like two seconds your
chunk okay let's go in here now it's
dark and there damn it you're spooking
candles okie dokie that's your trunk oh
we're level changing okay I couldn't
tell if anything was actually happening
or not Hannah is something over here did
I need to do anything in the boiler room
did I even really need to pull that
lever and what's
feeling feels like someone wants to
salvage of them
I love my spongebob references say what
was the noise coming from the boiler hey
where'd you go
hi where'd you go oh there you are hi No
thank you I don't want any where are you
going what are you doing hi hi what are
you doing what are you doing what are
you doing hi hi hey chop that hey hey
don't make me pull this lever cuz I will
and they'll be out of you're faster than
you can kay-kay
you can kay got it okay be gone no I'm
not gon do I gotta pull this lever hi
whoa boom whoa well you don't like that
now do you
oh no you don't oh that slowed you down
our amplitude sever one maybe okay I'm
gonna put I'm gonna do it well I'm doing
it ah you bet race
[ __ ] ha ha dodged you like a mouse god
I'm great
oh man I'm amazing thank you yeah
alright now where did we go hey wait a
minute
I remember this the boiler room yes of
course that's where I went before but
I'm going there now am i close to the
end of the game or something let's walk
towards the light good ride it oh boy
hello what's that
what could agree
maybe does it say your name on it yep
Samuel gusta Ronda from not very old to
dead
okie-dokie like once again I can't turn
he's bouncing back and forth alright
then everybody that was the end that was
a great custom story I mean I kind of
feel bad because there was a lot of
potential for some really good scare
thing there than kind of what I got
that's probably copyrighted music I've
had some trouble with that before in the
credits but I just want to make sure
that there's nothing there but anyway
that was an awesome custom story I love
all the custom content I mean the art
wasn't fantastic but not everyone's an
artist and he obviously has some talent
for map making so that was still really
good I mean it was really well done I'm
surprised a brute didn't our moose man
didn't make an entrance at all but oh
well what can you do it was still
fantastic had a lot of good scares had a
lot of good environments and a lot of
fun so try for yourselves give it a
rating if you want to you can find the
link in the description below so thank
you everybody so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
potentially chance on that
[Music]
it's a sound